first i want to pull up this story
because we only briefly mentioned it
governor waltz declares an emergency
he's bringing in police from ohio
and nebraska you mentioned that the
senate passed a 9 million
emergency fund they're bringing all
these other police so the verdict is
supposed to come soon
this this the state is declaring an
emergency they have the national guard
already on
on scene we don't know what the
verdict's going to be it's possible it's
going to be a hung jury
because that means they can't come to a
decision that seems possible
on the merits i've seen some legal
analysts say it's not guilty across the
board
however due to the politics some people
are saying either a hung jury or guilty
across the board i've been i've been
seeing the exact same thing when i
when i reach out to like the profession
like lawyer i think you're you know like
will chamberlain
there's other great lawyers that are
like are doing great analysis of every
right now
they don't see any way this could be
guilty but one thing they've
some of them have mentioned and said hey
this thing is so politicized that the
jury just might just do it anyway
um this whole thing and then um tim did
you get to see
um the prosecution's like last sentence
was like
oh um you guys say that george floyd
died because his heart was too big
uh you know uh he died because derek
shaven to his heart was too small which
was odd for me
on most on most final lines they they
end on like
a fact or something right this they go
off that but it kind of he
he more did it for like media i don't
know that's what i think i don't know
what you guys think the most watched
trial in history i guess
well so so first i'll ask you guys i
don't know if you've been following
i've been following the court case but
you guys have been on the ground so i
don't know if you've been following a
lot of the trial stuff
but i'm curious what you guys think
based on what you've already seen based
on your experience what's coming next
what's going to happen in minnesota
richie i mean i don't think it really
matters honestly
like verdict yeah and like we actually
when we were on the ground the last
night in brooklyn center
it i commented to jorge after the fact
it ended up being a completely peaceful
evening but at the beginning
like jorge was like inquiring to me like
you want to go live man and i was so
bugged out
by all the people all the anti-media
sentiment all the anti-corporation just
like
the anger in the crowd was so palpable
that jorge is like hitting me up and
like i knew that there was one of the
organizers in our area and i was just
like
jorie was like wow rich is kind of being
a jerk but i just like was i was bugged
out that honestly
even me acknowledging him was gonna tip
people
everyone was just so mad that i don't
know i think it's a powder keg that has
nothing to do with the actual realities
of the case or anything like that it's
just
it's going to pop off no matter what
happens because yeah yeah and it's just
like lockdowns it's economics it's
well i politics i just want to add a
little bit real quick i agree with
richard because when you talk to folks
on the ground
for them it's like if they don't hear
the word murder it just like doesn't
matter
and i think just i just think that no
matter what happens we're going to see
an
interruption um i'm going more off the
the like my
if it's like a prediction thing i
actually don't think the riots
are going to hit the magnitude that it
did last time i think last summer
too many factors rolled in coveted the
unemployment i mean i think
some people were making like 600 bucks
per week on unemployment i think all
that kind of factored into that
i don't know we could reach that um but
i agree which i just think
if for me if they don't hear the word
like murder in there
it's not it's not good but max
well they're second degree and
throughout yeah i mean he's on trial for
murder
just not premeditated murder yeah so she
wants first degree
i think i think it's true it's a good
point to say that they're going to say
he was never tried for the true crime of
first degree murder and
so no matter what what um how well of a
job do you think eric nelson did
with derrick shaw do you think you think
he at least put it put a good case in
from the jury with a
there's no i'll say this from
my personal opinion as someone who knows
nothing you know knows little about the
law relative any of these lawyers
i felt like the state failed to prove
its case they couldn't convince me
that like dude i made several videos
angry at chauvin
when all this went down and i was like
this is crazy and i was like he
shouldn't have done this
and then i watch this trial and i'm like
they did nothing to prove
that chauvin caused the death of george
floyd they only gave me maybe it
happened this way in fact the
prosecution said at one point maybe it
was his enlarged heart maybe not
but chauvin and i'm like whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa
maybe but by the way yeah it has to be
it doesn't
okay so in order to prove murder it has
to be beyond a reasonable doubt
that he intended to kill him in that
moment
in that space no it doesn't so i got
this wrong uh
it's because they're doing the felony
murder rule they're saying he had
he had to and he had to have the
intention to use force
against floyd for third for felony
assault that floyd died from so it's
this it's the it's a
it's the felony murder rule so okay so
if it's if you're attempting felony
assault then
they die as a result of it then it's
felony and for murder three
the the equivalent according to legal
instructions analysis would be like
murder three is if you're shooting a gun
randomly into a crowd and you kill
somebody
like you're doing something that can
result in death but you weren't
targeting somebody
so i got to be honest
or even the the the the charges tim we
were talking about that how like they
weren't even
you were saying that they will probably
won't even get to 40 years which is
probably gonna anger
you know this crowd they i watched the
defense
and i was shocked when i heard the
prosecution's own witness admit
derek chauvin could have used more force
even a taser if he wanted to
that was the state's witness on cross
saying this and as soon as i heard that
i was like okay i'm done
now you mean to tell me that you're
you're claiming he committed assault
against george floyd
and he could have legally used more
force than he did then how was what he
did a felony assault
he used less force and was allowed to as
a cop i'm not happy it happened man
but if the cop if your own witness is
saying that
so so i'll say this the state did a bad
job
the defense did a pretty good job near
the end the state started doing a bit of
a better job
hitting the points they needed to hit
and the defense slipped on their own
expert witness
but ultimately after looking at
everything it was just the state's own
witnesses
firing shots back at them and hurting
their case and
it looks like the defense's strategy the
whole time was to have a short
uh uh short case so that the state went
for several days
then uh uh the defense was substantially
less i think they only had like two or
three witnesses
but then they did like three hours of
closing arguments laying out all of the
cases i got to tell you man
the defense is closing arguments wow
it's uh
um for me it's beyond a reasonable doubt
but what i'm saying is
i have if it's reasonable doubt that he
committed a crime is all it takes for me
i i think they've actually proven
chauvin's innocence but is this
one case this particular example is it's
just too politicized that the jury's
going to say you know what
we got to convict this guy because it's
either our life or the cities or across
the u.s
i don't know this one is a is the city a
city council woman
voted to fire the city manager and she
said it's because i was scared they
would retaliate against me
so i think the jury's sitting there and
they're and they're going like i don't
care about this guy
he's guilty no matter what anyone says
because i don't want to get shot that's
that's where i think they're at i mean
well i don't know
i don't know i mean at a certain point
like you said
i mean you're that's your civic duty
right and you're you've
whether you like it or not you've
stepped into that role like
am i gonna cater my what i saw on the
night of kenosha just because i feel
like
people want me to say one thing or
another like
no obviously not and like you at a
certain point
you know if you're serving
you gotta you gotta determine what role
you're serving in that particular
situation
and if you're witness or if you're jury
member you have to just do your best and
then
i mean i don't know if someone wants to
you know
if it were me on the jury and after
everything i've seen
i'd be saying not guilty um i could
probably be
convinced of maybe manslaughter like if
we had if someone if we if we argued
over one of the evidence and i heard
compelling case but i'd probably still
be leaning towards not guilty
and i'm not gonna i'm not gonna change
my views based on what antifa the left
or the media would say of me
i tweeted that you know the kyle writing
situation
convinced me to finally like was one of
the things that finally convinced me i
got to vote for trump
because the way the media was lying and
portraying everything and demonizing
this this kid
who far from perfect but still it was
you know self-defense
if if the media is going to be i have no
comment on that obviously no for sure
for sure yeah but
for me that's what i felt like and then
trump pinned the tweet
and it became a talking point the white
house press corps was asking
the you know uh caitlyn mcinerney like
trump pinned this tweet
i'm gonna say what i think even if
they're gonna smear me over it
if antifa threatens me i'll exactly i'll
tell you this i gotta be honest
i'm the kind of person to where if one
of these antifa guys or anybody
threatens me i double down
yeah i'd like bring it i've gotten i
mean i've gotten that way i've gotten
them from both sides because also i'm a
victim in the criminal complaint
so like the people who support
you know who are auntie kyle rittenhouse
have come after me because like oh
you know whatever this guy's a terrorist
blah blah blah and then the other side
is saying you're a wuss you know you're
not
you're not a victim and like i just i
just have to say
what i experienced you know in the
moment so like what and the prosecution
might take what i say and you know
make it to suit their role in the
situation it's just an adversarial
relationship
it's really fascinating watching a trial
like this and you really start to
understand
framing perception perspective and
it's really it's really it's really
really interesting how the truth
can be massaged by both sides to
fit their needs and like how you can
omit certain information to change
especially when you're the guy stuck in
and i remember when i woke up
i didn't actually view my role like very
um i didn't you know think oh this is
really my duty to do it until
the next morning i saw a vice article
just saying open fire
um and that terminology like is just
it's no concern for what happened on the
ground it was like okay now okay
i can't wait until the trial i obviously
have to say something before but there's
politics at play man
i i'd imagine you're going to get a lot
more heat from the left
i don't know i i've honestly gotten a
lot of crap from
um from the right from the from the pro
kyle i i don't know
honestly like i don't really i don't
think it matters like who i'm getting
crap from
because i'm still gonna stay the same no
matter what it's pretty simple
it's just what i saw and heard but at
the same time it has been
definitely an educational experience
that maybe i can talk about after the
trial
because until then i'm just going to try
my best yeah i think there was
also two on the con right house there's
just that story i believe there was that
man who like worked
in the medical field and he like donated
like 10 bucks yes into kyle rent
journalist was like we're doing an
investigation we're at his front door
and asking him about his donut it's like
dude it's 10 bucks i mean okay you know
you know i think i think it was
despicable
if if it were me though i don't know if
the guy answered him or whatever
if like a reporter knocked on my door
first i'd be like did you see the no
trespassing son
like you can go but if it was a reporter
like we want to get a comment i
i i have left to hit me up for like
ridiculous stories i
answer them it's the best of my
abilities yeah exactly i think there's
a lot to be said for that instead of
shutting it down well
i see a lot of conservatives will be
like no to a request for comment
i had someone hit me from a leftist
smear machine and i wrote him a book
like i wrote like 3 000 words yeah went
in depth and like bold things and i'm
like
i got all the time today to talk about
what i think so like here you go man
have at it
and i'm very respectful and nice i'm
like appreciate that you reached out and
gave me the opportunity to save my piece
and
hope uh wish the best for you and have a
good day good stuff and then but then
when people see that from that outlet
then that basically transcends that
gap that we're talking about that schism
between the two trenches like
what they do is when you supply them
with enough words they
they can selectively pull you out
because but that's why you got to fight
that battle like
i have basically been fighting that
battle to get
you know my word out to both sides and i
think actually the one piece that i'm
most proud of
came out on the huffington post and mary
to her credit like basically wrote this
entire
article about uh rosenbaum's last
moments and just because of where
people perceive me as coming from
politically they didn't care about my
account of that but
you know those are the same people that
are supposed to be saying you know this
guy
died um and we should remember him
and so like that account of his last
moments i think is important to just
bring back bring people back to the
humanity of doesn't matter what this
guy's
ideology is it doesn't matter the fact
that he literally came from a mental
hospital
apparently right before he got shot and
then i had people
all over the place why did you try to
save that that sexual
pedo or why did you try to it's like
dude if somebody's dying in front of you
that's the point it doesn't matter what
their ideology is this is interesting
though because the defense
in the chauvin trial pointed out this is
not about the perspective of a doctor
who's watched hundreds of hours of
footage for
for a year is that about the perspective
of you know individuals who showed up
after everything already happened and
then told you their experience it's the
perspective of the officer who was there
and what he felt what he perceived and
what he knew and derek chauvin is not
a you know cardiopulmonologist who
understands what a seizure is
his perspective is george floyd kicking
is a resisting arrest
now a doctor may watch that later and
say that was a seizure but how would a
street cop know that
for you when you see a guy shot he's on
the ground how are you supposed to know
what his history is
or where he came from all you know
there's a guy in front of me bleeding
i have no idea who the guy is he could
be a saint for all i know it could be a
local youth pastor
or you could be a you know a diddler
exactly and by the way kyle
kyle ran back up behind me after the
shooting and i screamed at him to call
9-1-1
not even concerned with who it was or
whatever
and then you know after the fact
realizing it's the guy who had he had a
gun right behind me but
my concern was like for one thing it's
humanity
yeah and you know i was like excuse me
what are your politics
uh it's like hindsight is 20 20 it's
like aoc when she lied about what
happened at the capitol
the fascinating thing about it she she
she told that story where she like hid
in her bathroom and she was like oh no
they got in the building
that story was clearly fabricated
because it included details you would
only know in hindsight
at the time that aoc went to you know at
the time she sighted
was like you know just around 1 p.m no
one had gotten any
any buildings there was no one even
trying to get any buildings only because
a day later
we saw what happened she now says at
that time i was scared they got in the
building
because she's calling upon the the anger
and the fear people had from the
building being breached
but that morning nobody knew that was
going to happen that's how you know she
made it up
people often forget about situational
context so they look at like the written
house thing and they're like why didn't
you why did you help that guy who's a
bad person you're like
you found that out like a month later
yeah i i'm i'm there on the ground
i don't know if this guy's taking a
seizure i don't know if he's a criminal
i just know that there's a guy in front
of me who's resisting or i know this guy
in front of me was hurt
and it's always easy for people on the
outside to say oh you should have done
this
should have done that until they're in
that moment and i think
i i don't know if you want to maybe add
on this rich i think what maybe happened
to you was just fight or flight right i
think
you know i mean there's yeah there's no
there was no time to make any decisions
and like i don't know i mean i look back
it's like
could i have done anything else to yeah
for me like knowing you know richie
personally and and you know working
under him
you know to me when i heard that i was
like man like it feels good to
be associated with someone that is
willing to do that for someone like yeah
i was like i felt you know you feel the
moment probably hey i'm glad that like
to call him like my editor or whatever
because to me that was like
you know when people ask me like what
would you do i'm like i'm out i mean i'm
out so i i don't think i could have done
the same thing so i think it was
it was a brave thing to do and uh yeah i
thought i thought it was something it
didn't matter at the end of the day
you know ultimately like was there
anything that could have been done to
save his life
like the toothpaste can't go back into
the tube but you just think to yourself
like
why did that situation exist in the
first place and
the only thing that i can do from here
is to take that human experience and
actually you know try to express to
people that you know
like it's not just a video game and like
i've seen so many times when we have
these crazy situations unfolding in
front of us and people are just on their
phones
and they're just keen on like what the
next tweet is and like
at a certain point the game becomes
reality and it's like people
suffer and die as a result of what we're
seeing on the ground right now
and it's not just people who die there
it's people who die as a result of the
narrative
you know that it's like how many people
are economically suffering because
you know this news outlet wants to push
this narrative or whatever
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you